welcome to the friday show i have a few
stories i want to run through before we
move on to
other things including your questions we
talked
last week about the continued
possibility that donald trump will start
his own political party we also saw a
poll showing
that nearly two-thirds of republican
voters
are in theory willing to leave the
republican party and follow trump to a
new party now of course if donald trump
started a new party
and forget about 64 percent if donald
trump trump took 50
or 40 or even 30 percent of republican
voters to a new party
it could spell absolute disaster for the
american rights splitting the vote and
allowing
the democratic party to um win a lot
to take a phrase out of donald trump's
vocabulary
there's now another new story and this
is being reported by reuters there are
dozens of former republican officials
who view the republican party as
unwilling to stand
up to donald trump so this is an
anti-trump group
of former republican officials and what
these individuals are saying is
if the republican party won't stand up
to trump and say no we reject
trumpism and we reject trump they are in
discussions
to break away from the republican party
and start their own
and this includes former officials uh in
the republican administrations of ronald
reagan george h.w bush george w bush
as well as even disaffected trump aides
and staffers and uh
political employees this includes some
ex-republican ambassadors this includes
some republican strategists and others
and 120 of them had a zoom call
of course last friday to have a
conversation about this
and the idea is they would say the
republican party has become the party of
trump
we are getting back to principled
conservatism
as they call it what that means is
pretending to care about the debt and
deficit let's not mistake that for
anything else but
it doesn't matter because again this
could also be an
absolute and total disaster for the
republican party
one of the people involved is evan
mcmullen you might remember he ran
third party in 2016 former uh cia
agent i believe and he is part of this
movement for a possible splinter party i
have to tell you that this is
fantastic news um imagine if we got but
these would be two gifts
if donald tru you've got the republican
party and within it you have people who
want to stick with trump
and people who want the republican party
to completely denounce
and distance from donald trump you could
have a situation
where so-called principled conservatives
in the republican party
split off and start their own party to
get away from trump and at the same time
donald trump starts his own party and
takes
the hyper pro-trump people away as well
so you could end up with the trump party
taking away from the republican party
the principled conservative
former republicans who are anti-trump
splitting off from the republican party
and then i guess what you'd have left in
the republican party are just generally
people not paying much attention or who
don't don't uh really feel strongly one
way or the other and they just want to
keep voting for people like i don't know
lindsey graham
um and then they stay and you could have
a republican party split
three ways it i i have no interest in
giving advice to these folks about what
they should do
i simply recognize the mathematical
realities that
even if trump splits off and takes 15
percent of the party
and these principled conservatives split
off and take
10 or 15 of the party uh that
creates a situation in which republicans
as we know them or in any of these new
iterations
don't win for a decade and if there
would ever be an opportunity
for the left to make progress in the
united states it would be that now
unfortunately
the democratic party has shown itself so
often to be
so incompetent that it would probably
still end up being a challenge
for a democratic party given the gift of
a republican party divided three ways
it would probably still end up being an
uphill battle for the modern democratic
party
to make progress but at least they'd
have the opportunity uh we'll follow it
very very interesting stuff
one of our sponsors is four sigmatic the
company
best known for their delicious mushroom
coffee
four sigmatics mushroom coffee is
organic
fair trade single origin arabica coffee
with both lion's mane and chaga
mushrooms chaga mushrooms have actually
been shown to have potential in
supporting the immune system in
peer-reviewed studies
i've been drinking four sigmatic coffee
a lot lately it actually doesn't taste
anything like mushrooms it just tastes
like any
delicious coffee but it's really easy on
my stomach doesn't give me any jittery
feeling
or a midday crash and they have over 20
000 five-star reviews and best of all
if you don't love it you'll get 100
percent of your money back
because they stand behind their product
you've got nothing to lose by giving it
a try
four sigmatic is giving my audience up
to forty percent off
and free shipping when you go to four
sigmatic dot com slash pacman the link
is right underneath this video